Speaker 1: We are going to hear from the
most important people in our ecosystem,
the viewers, the listeners, the audience. If it
weren't for you, there would be no show. I would
probably still own a microphone, but I wouldn't
be able to do anything interesting with it. That's
for damn sure. We take calls via discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. The waiting lobby
is where you go. If you want to chat with me
and let's see the degree of technical problems
that will plague us today. I want to start here
with Alex from Baltimore. Alex from Baltimore,
welcome. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All righty.
So first question. I've been meaning to ask you.
Anyone who listens to your live calls and
livestreams knows you're very particular
about your bagels. So as someone who is a little
more vagal, illiterate, for lack of a better term,
what makes a David Pakman approved bagel?
Speaker 1: Well, you need the right ratio
of crunchy on the outside and pillowy soft
on the inside. It's almost an ethereal thing
that's beyond description. You just need
to bite into it and you know, right away.
Speaker 2: And it doesn't matter, like
the topping of Bagel or the horse.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, you're not going
to see me with a French toast bagel anytime
soon. Of course, the topic matters. Absolutely.
The really if you're looking for a sweet bagel,
you go cinnamon raisin. But all of these, you
know, strawberry bagels, French toast, oatmeal,
pancake bagel, chocolate chip nutter.
No, no, it's not for me. I'm a purist.
Speaker 2: I agree. Savory bagels are
better than sweet bagels. I would say.
Speaker 1: I would say so.
Speaker 2: Okay. All right.
Real question. So this is based
off of a book I read recently.
Would you say is would you give any credence
to the idea that. The president of the United
States just flat out has too much to
handle and that no matter who it is.
What their beliefs are. They're just
going to have a hard time and they're
not going to be particularly good at their job.
Speaker 1: No, I don't agree with that. I mean,
I think there's sort of two different
questions here. There is the question
of does the president of the United States
have too many responsibilities in terms of
delegation? And then there's the separate
question of whether they're all going to be
bad at their jobs. I think that there are lots of
presidents who were good at their jobs. I mean,
President Obama was good at his job. You never
got the sense that he just couldn't keep up with
all the different things that were under his
purview. I think the more interesting question
or maybe the more accurate assessment that
could be made is there there simply need to be
significantly more diplomats, because as we know,
a lot of these issues, they touch the presidency,
but then they're the details are sort of handled
by the diplomatic corps, that the diplomatic corps
should be bolstered and should be bigger. I think
that's a fair assessment to make. But of course,
the right says we need the smallest
possible government. So by definition,
they're against enlarging the diplomatic corps.
Speaker 2: Gotcha. And the book is The Hardest
Job in the World by John DICKERSON, who's on CBS,
actually. Yeah, it was actually it was actually
an interesting book. That wasn't his only point.
It was also like a mini history of the presidency
and how even like mundane responsibilities,
like evolving kind of pile up on on their day
to day and make the job a little harder. Another
slight thing they he said was. How the president
also has to be a great campaigner and great
at governing. True that a lot of people can't.
Aren't necessarily the best at doing both.
Like I'm sure there's a bunch of senators
who would be great presidents. I think of a Amy
Klobuchar or a. Elizabeth Warren, but who on the
stump just don't seem to impress anybody. So but
they would be great. Once they got in the chair.
Speaker 1: I would go even further. There's
I completely agree. There's people who
would never even run because the idea of the
political campaign is so off putting to them,
who would still be really good presidents
if they somehow ended up in that position.
So I absolutely agree with that.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And that was just a.
That was just a good point. I thought. All right.
That's all I had. I will talk to you next time.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you very
much for the call. I appreciate it